["Fanfare for the Common
Man" playing].
>>Teacher: -- the most important
things we learn about the galaxy,
the great power of the universe.
And please look around you--
>>Narrator: This is
the digital generation.
>>Girl: I text more
than I call people.
Like no one calls anyone anymore.
>>Girl: My iPod is
like my entire life.
>>Narrator: A generation of
kids raised in a media rich,
networked world of
infinite possibilities.
>>Boy: A lot of my movies
are special effects,
things that you really
couldn't do in real life.
>>Narrator: They are learning,
communicating and socializing
in new and exciting ways.
>>Boy: I'm showing video to the
other people that are in the meeting
to get them to help review.
>>Narrator: For them,
technology is more than a tool.
It's an essential component
of everyday life
that frames their world view.
>>Girl: These are all different
people in need in Haiti,
and click on one of these families.
Learn more.
>>Narrator: But there's
more to their world
than just playing with cool gadgets.
It's about engagement.
>>Girl: Okay, guys, join.
>>Narrator: Self directed learning.
>>Boy: It's not just animation.
You need to know a lot
of different things
like biology, to see how things move.
>>Narrator: Creativity.
>>Girl: This is my avatar
as she typically will look.
>>Narrator: And empowerment.
>>Girl: Do you think there
can be people that will try
and hurt you on a website?
>>I'm teaching young, elementary
kids how to stay safe online.
>>Narrator: They're hyper connected
to their friends and family,
mastering new tools and
techniques with ease.
>>Girl: I like this
'cause it's competitive
and it's really using
strategy in your mind.
>>Henry: For those kids who
become leaders of guilds in World
of Warcraft, that's as much an
experience as being the captain
of the football team, being the
editor of the school newspaper.
>>Narrator: Behind every successful
kid are adults and peers who guide,
motivate and support them.
>>Akili : Kids on their
own are jumping
across from all these different
mediums, so we really need
to kinda explore all of them as
well, and try to support kids
to become better producers
and consumers.
>>Did you put sound in it?
>>Boy: It's annoying.
I don't like it anymore.
>>Kevin: Very rarely, the kids look
at instruction manuals these days.
They are empowered to just go out
and learn, and if I'm a parent
and I'm wondering, "Wow, how do I
provide the technology resources
for my children?"
just get outta their way.
>>Liz Perle: Hey, this digital
life, it's a good thing.
It's gonna help your kids
create, meet people, explore,
compose, express themselves.
They have more powerful
tools than they've ever had
in any generation in history.
>>Narrator: This is
the digital generation.
Welcome to their world.